Avengers, assemble — for a funeral.
According to a new rumor making the rounds,
a major character in the cast of Avengers:
Infinity War will meet their maker in the
very first few moments of the movie, kicking
off the epic battle with a point for Thanos's
team.
Citing "a reliable source", ScreenGeek has
published a report hinting at "the death of
a major Marvel character," and that the death
will have huge consequences, both in this
movie and the adventures to come.
The source states:
"Some fans will be expecting it, while others
will be blindsided.
It sets the tone for the rest of the movie
— as well as the future of the MCU."
It's hard to respond to this news by doing
anything other than throwing out guesses.
In response to the report, ScreenCrush drew
a connecting line between this news and a
previous quote from Marvel head Kevin Feige
at Brazil's Comic-Con, in which he stated
that Thanos would establish himself, quote,
"within the first five minutes" of the movie.
"Thanos shows us why he's the biggest, baddest
villain we've ever had."
There aren't too many candidates that fit
the framework other than Loki, the trickster
god who was last seen at the end of Thor:
Ragnarok standing side-by-side with his brother
as they encountered Thanos's massive ship.
While we don't know exactly what happens after
the sons of Odin meet Thanos, we do know that
Thor makes it out of the encounter alive,
sailing through space to encounter the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
So… where's Loki?
Avengers: Infinity War will be out in theaters
worldwide on April 27th.
Until then, be wary of decoy spoilers that
may circulate to preserve the movie's twist.
Remember: Thanos demands your silence.
We're almost there, folks — fingers crossed
that your favorite character makes it out
alive.
As the ScreenGeek source said,
"It's good that the Russo Brothers are telling
fans to be emotionally prepared for the film
— because they'll definitely need to be.
Whether you're expecting it or not, it's going
to be big."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!